so a lot of people were very excited for
both of you joining
the uh the mcu for very different
reasons uh and i'm curious for each of
you what does it mean to have joined the
mcu um what does it mean to yourself you
know what i mean well for me you know
i'm just a huge fan of the mcu i'm a big
nerd as you know big geek i grew up
reading comic books playing video games
watching movies i love these movies i've
i've been watching superhero movies
since i can remember they're my favorite
and i love sci-fi and so
it was exciting to me because this is
exactly my favorite genre of movie like
two of them together like a big sci-fi
philosophically dense epic
and a superhero movie at the same time
so i i mean i can't believe my luck
yes you made me remember this one time
that i stole my sister's um box of
marvel comics
and i left them outside in the rain and
her whole collection ended up getting
soaked
i don't know maybe this kind of makes up
for that in a way
sorry to my sister
100
do you guys think that um if the
eternals were allowed to fight thanos on
their own that um that they would have
won or would thanos have beaten them
i
think that you just described our next
movie right
[Laughter]
yeah
let's do it
yes
i mean you know listen you're trying to
get in
us into trouble with your controversial
questions and we are not taking debate
are we more powerful than the people who
fought
thanos in game
i mean the fact that your aunt's asking
the question kind of answers the
question right of course i i get it um
uh when when you guys were meeting with
chloe and with marvel to talk about your
roles in the movie did you guys get into
these conversations of how powerful is
my character what can i actually do like
what damage would kill me like did you
ask those kinds of questions did you
debate who's the most powerful eternal
can you sort of talk about that
the first time that i sat down with
chloe and nate
um nate moore it was more about just
broad strokes
and
one of the most interesting things that
happened in the conversation that we had
it was more about
who are you lauren who are you they
wanted to know who i was they wanted to
know about my interests they wanted to
know what i did in my daily life how i
faced challenges if i confronted
problems what that looked like
and i'm glad i mean i didn't walk away
from that meeting with a lot of
information about the character um but i
talked about what i could bring to that
character
yeah and for me you know they actually
changed my power at one point i was
going to be uh really good with swords i
was gonna have two swords and that was
at the first meeting and the second
meeting chloe was like no i don't want
to have swords he's gonna do finger guns
and i was like finger guns that sounds
so goofy she's like trust me it's gonna
look great
she was right it looks great
you know what's interesting to me uh
about this movie in superpowers is that
you have sort of icarus who um has the
more traditional superhero powers right
he flies he shoots beams his powers are
like physical strength on the other end
of the spectrum you have cersei whose
powers are
very nature based right she turns things
into flowers she she can she can change
like nature she can affect matter those
are two very different kinds of power so
so to me it was exciting to do a
superhero movie where you really can
sort of get into
what traditional superhero powers are
and what is a different version of that
that perhaps has been discounted
previously
on that note i need to stop i'm just
going to say thank you for your time and
i really sincerely hope this is a huge
hit
for real
oh man tell everybody to see it
i definitely shall
[Laughter]
thank you so much for your time have a
great day
you